un retorno a la vida prepandémica para
estos fanáticos de la música francesa es
el primer concierto bajo techo en
francia desde marzo de 2020 en el
escenario del estilo de parís bercy la
banda indochine y 5.000 asistentes todo
como parte de un experimento de la
autoridad hospitalaria de parís aunque
para estos aficionados se trataba de la
música
han pasado casi dos años desde que
tuvimos un concierto no habíamos visto
el estadio de bercy ni ningún otro
escenario lleno y no hemos tenido del
ambiente de concierto
si descubren que no funciona tal vez
este podría ser el único concierto que
se realiza sin distanciamiento fue
importante estar aquí la multitud para
el concierto de prueba estuvo compuesta
únicamente por personas entre 18 y 45
años sin condiciones médicas a todos les
realizaron tests antes del concierto y
serán sometidos pronto a otra prueba de
kobe 19 el uso de mascarillas fue
obligatorio y se instalaron cámaras para
monitorear si los asistentes estaban
respetando las medidas en punto es ver
si a estar muy cerca unos de otros
incluso con mascarilla tendrá un impacto
lo averiguaremos con los resultados
hemos redescubierto la vida antes de la
pandemia obviamente tenemos mascarillas
e hicimos dos o tres pruebas antes de
haber los organizadores realizaron
pruebas de saliva a los participantes al
ingresar al recinto una operación
precisa porque para la industria de la
música en vivo hay mucho en juego
en estos momentos estamos preparando la
programación de otoño si se va a
reanudar también queremos que se
reanuden todos los eventos incluidos
eventos de pie que suponen el 60% de
nuestra actividad en el sector musical
como el que estamos trabajando esta
noche
y los resultados del experimento se
darán a conocer a finales de junio y si
son concluyentes los conciertos podrán
reanudarse en septiembre con las
restricciones vigentes de kobe 19